hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 90 something
90 what is it 98. it's 98. um
it is uh
you've probably noticed it's autumn
autumn is no longer coming it's here so
saddle up the direwolves we ride tonight
wow
all right you didn't see that coming i i
i did not i forgot to source any
direwolves when i was down at the
farmers market this morning but i think
actually now that i
now that i reflect on what i was finding
it was like it's that amazing season uh
where we're still getting the berries
and now and the stone fruits and we're
also getting many of the fall like the
brassicas and such and um i did not see
any dire wolves there this morning on
offer not a one not a one that's a shame
maybe they're not at the farmer's market
uh were there farmers there if so that
implies the dire worlds are not at least
dense on the ground that's probably true
yeah
all right
we've got stuff to do we got stuff to
talk about uh today we're going to talk
about um we're going to talk about our
our book continuing to and some of the
critique some of the um yeah critique
that is
uh
come at it and um and you know what
critique is and what it is doing in the
world and its value we're gonna talk
about some of the earliest americans
some new um some a new scientific result
out this week
which is consistent with the view of the
peopling of the americas that we uh
reflect on in uh in our book um and in
service of that we're also going to talk
about this concept of stolen land and
understanding human history and how
history is often being taught
and um and a couple of weeks ago or so
in the q a we got asked if we knew of
this roger scrutin essay called dying in
time and neither of us did
and i have since read it and uh we're
going to share a little bit of it and
talk about the value of of courage
all right uh but before we do that we
have some logistics okay um
if you've gotten the book a hunter
gatherer's guide to the 21st century
evolution of the challenges of modern
life and you have enjoyed it please
consider
giving a review that said amazon has
been sold out since three days after
publication date and it remains
sold out to this day we know there are
more books coming
but
if you are looking for it barnes and
noble still has copies and we encourage
you to go there most local book sellers
apparently are out as well
um it is there are more more copies
coming but supply chains and um
the incredible response to this book
have both
caused there to be shortages where we
were hoping there would not be any
should point out though that the
audiobook is doing spectacularly well
anomalously well which might partially
be because our our voices are well known
and so people are preferring that mode
but it also may be that people who
aren't finding the hardcover are are
buying that and hopefully they will
enjoy it it is read by us yep it is it
is read by us and um
strangely it's not available in um in a
large part of the world and i think that
may also be a supply chain issue it is a
supply chain issue yes the supply of
vibrations of air molecules is
apparently not
sufficient to meet the demand yeah yeah
no that's um it's really
hard to fathom and uh the
the publisher on the other side of the
pond is is working on it's not their
fault it's unclear why but uh for those
of you in other english-speaking parts
of the world who are looking for the
audiobook it should it is available
apparently everywhere but audible but um
audible in the uk not not so much
um okay if you're watching on youtube
consider switching over to odyssey
that's where the chat is happening if
you are watching live and you want to be
participating in the chat
you may
ask us questions we're going to try to
prioritize questions about the book this
week but there's always there's always
room for a lot more and you can ask
questions at www.darkhorseadmissions.com
consider joining our patreons tomorrow
is the monthly private q a on my patreon
the questions have already been asked
for this month um but it's small enough
it's intimate enough
uh that we are able to engage the chat
in real time and often can can respond
to questions that are asked in real time
and then those stay up afterwards for um
for patrons to watch if they can't do it
in real time
um so that's tomorrow at 11 a.m from 11
to 1 uh pacific time
and maybe we'll just go right to our ads
before then jumping into the main part
of the program
so visual listeners
visual watchers i suppose will see the
border around the screen indicating that
we are reading ads for those of you who
are listening if you would put on your
ad colored glasses that would be useful
very very good yep so we have three
sponsors this week
again as we've said before we only take
sponsors for products that we actually
stand behind and we have rejected many
people who have approached many
companies that have approached us
not because necessarily they're products
we don't approve of but just that we
have no ability to have a relationship
with uh so the three that we are uh
bringing to you this week are are ones
that we have brought before vevo
barefoot four sigmatic and omax
cryofreeze vivo barefoot is on a mission
to create regenerative footwear and
experiences that bring you closer to
nature and your natural potential it
makes shoes for feet that sounds
unremarkable perhaps until you realize
that most shoes are not made for your
feet they're made for someone's idea of
what feet should look like and do and be
constrained by most shoemakers seem to
have no idea what feet are or what they
should be able to do and we
have were sent by people barefoot a few
pairs each and we've been wearing them
for a few months now and they have aside
from when we're in cleats for biking or
or otherwise need specialized shoes
this is what we are both wearing we love
them they it feels like you're barefoot
but you have the protection of shoes you
get better tactile feedback from the
surfaces you're walking on they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions and it's actually
ridiculous how fantastic they are and to
to that point i will say that when we
were flying back from texas a couple
weeks ago a guy sitting across from me
across the aisle for me on the plane
asked me about the shoes and he was
wearing them too he said i don't see
them out here very often but i love
these shoes
he's a runner he said i run in them so
he's actually using them as running
shoes
and as everyday shoes as you know plain
going shoes and we had a little
conversation about how we both uh wished
that they were more widespread because
we imagined that people will um you know
have a better relationship with walking
and with their own bodies if they would
be wearing shoes that are this well
designed with this much of a sense of
what it is that the human foot is and
has been and how not to impair it uh
with with footwear so um you know i
could go on and on and on but let me
just go right to the call to action here
go to vivobarefoot.com
darkhorse to get an exclusive offer of
20 off
additionally all new customers get a 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's vevo
barefoot
b a v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e e f o o t dot com
slash darkhorse
second ad all right before sigmatic
uh that's f o u r sigmatic
um
this is a wellness company known for its
delicious mushroom coffee i know that
sounds weird and kind of off-putting i
was skeptical but i've been drinking it
lately most mornings and it's really
really good it contains coffee as you
might expect although um from the name
you might think maybe it's just
mushrooms but no it's got organic fair
trade single origin arabica coffee and
also has lion's mane mushroom for
productivity and chaga mushroom for
immune support
it adds for me i think a little
something some christmas some focus the
world seems a little more clear after
drinking it it's delicious just like
regular coffee if you like that sort of
thing as i do you can't taste the
mushrooms it's if that's what you're
worried about but it tastes just like
your favorite coffee dark and nutty and
delicious
this like all of four sigmatic products
are organic vegan gluten free
every single batch is third party tested
to ensure it's purity and safety so you
know you're getting the highest quality
coffee and mushrooms possible
and they back all of their products with
100 money back guarantee love every sip
or get your money back
so we have an exclusive offer with four
sigmatic on their best-selling mushroom
coffee but just for dark horse listeners
get up to 40 off and free shipping on
mushroom coffee bundles you go to
4sigmatic.com that's f o u r s i g m a t
i c dot com dark horse
and save up to 40 and get free shipping
so for sigmatic.com darkhorse fuel your
productivity and creativity with some
delicious mushroom coffee all right
omax cryofreeze
let us talk about pain pain is an
adaptation it does various things for
you it tells you when you are doing
damage to something and you should stop
it tells you when you are at risk of
doing
damage to something and it can train you
to avoid behaviors that might cause
damage however
much pain that is chronic is not useful
it's simply annoying it distracts you
and it causes you to pay less attention
to other things
omax cryofreeze is a cbd based
product that allows you to deal with
chronic pain you just roll it on it
smells good i think a very light smell
but it smells good it's not sticky or
otherwise
gross
it is it isn't greasy it's 100 natural
and it is designed to block pain
receptors right at the location where
you have pain so for example if you've
been driving too much i did some
driving uh recently and got out of the
car and felt a bit stiff in the shoulder
put it on it works well
all right so omax health is offering our
listeners twenty percent off a full
bottle of cryofreeze cbd pain relief
roll on
this discount also applies towards any
product site-wide just go to
omaxhealth.com today and enter the code
darkhorse
that's
omax omax health a-t-a-l-t-h
dot com and enter the code dark horse
and get 20 off cryo-freeze or any other
product site-wide
[Music]
all right
that's our ads
let's talk about let's talk about
critique let's do it
critique is an utterly necessary part of
many aspects of human endeavor science
for sure
art as well it looks a little bit
different in general in art
but anyone who has taken for instance
studio art classes understands uh the
value and the and the necessary place of
critique um in assessing even something
um
like art which might be understood to be
you know sometimes representational but
even so there is obviously
interpretation involved all right i want
to stop here so i have said that very
often we have a term in which there's
the legitimate version of something and
the malignant version and
there's a question about whether we
should be saying i think critique
is one of the most useful things in the
universe very hard to come by because in
general people have perverse incentives
even people who are on your team may not
want to give you honest feedback because
they don't want to hurt your feelings or
it may complicate your relationship and
so getting honest feedback is fantastic
it's the thing that allows you to
navigate and improve but it's tough but
it's delivered and it's tough to receive
right
yeah nobody likes deli you know
delivering uh critique to somebody that
they value right so it's it's a
um an important but rare phenomenon in
the universe
and it is different from criticism which
can be motivated by all kinds of things
right so maybe critique is a version of
criticism it's a
an honorable exploration of what might
be changed or improved or what isn't
right rather than just simply uh
the
allegation that something isn't right
which may or may not be well-founded is
that fair yeah i think that is fair um i
think
um some forms of critique um
are uh more common in some cultures than
others and i think they're also it also
may be gendered in fact i'm certain that
it is so with regard to cultures i think
for instance
um
somewhat stereotypically but accurately
uh the the jewish dinner table tends to
be one in which there's talking over one
another and there's disagreement and
it's often very lively
and
none of that disagreement which
sometimes is critique
is imagined to be about um hatefulness
or discouragement of thinking into areas
where you might be wrong or more capable
of making errors than in others right
it's all it's about it's a it's exactly
about in being in service of both um the
you know the family dynamic and
community and also truth
right and uh i'm i'm hesitant here
because i don't have a lot of experience
with japanese culture but the reputation
of
japanese culture is that the critique is
delivered
so subtly that one has to read deeply in
in order to get it it's not that it
isn't there but um but the point is your
calibration has to be very different
right because you're expecting for
somebody to just say flat out hey this
is what you did wrong and here's what
you might do and somebody is really you
know
if it's written between the lines or
something like that you may have to go
after it in order to even get the value
of it and of course you know if in your
home culture you will be expected to
understand exactly the form that the
critique comes in and be either unable
to detect or flabbergasted by the
directness of critique that may come at
you depending on you know which end of
the spectrum your home culture happened
to have and i would say
um that we also know this you know
cultural differences are different from
sex differences because every single
culture
has both sexes and always has and so you
know this is this is one of the many
reasons that the kinds of isms that
people talk about um are not simply of a
type right um that sexism um and sex
differences are very different than say
racism and um possible race differences
but
something that i have been thinking
about a lot of late and i've begun to
talk about a little bit and some of the
very many interviews we've been doing
about the book
is the differences in
male and female
strategies with regard to establishing
and maintaining dominance uh that uh you
know we all need because we are now
living in a world thankfully gratefully
in which men and women can interact
as you know on a par as equals in the
intellectual space
but pretending that we don't have
differences that
that are more ancient than that ability
is is a fool's errand
and uh in general across species that
have them and certainly across human
cultures and time and space we see that
dominance hierarchies in males are
typically created and maintained by
rather overt mechanisms
and in the form of critique that would
be being really direct you know saying
very directly actually no i think you're
wrong here's why
and uh female dominance hierarchies both
in other species and in humans
throughout time and space are much more
likely to be covert in nature and so use
um more more subtlety more nuance
sometimes going around um you know
skirting the actual person with whom you
might have a critique and talking to
someone else about it and you know on on
these topics i have much much more to
say um and you know
i am not making value judgment here i am
observing what we know to be true
um but this is part of the reason that
men and women coming together into sort
of professional spaces often have
problems um that the nature of how we
expect on average you know population
level differences critique to come and
how it feels um to a woman say if
someone is very direct or to a man if
someone is really not direct um you know
a man is less likely to hear the
critique and that's not necessarily
because he's being daft it may be
because that's really not the culture
that he comes from and a woman may be
more likely to feel
attacked by a direct critique even if
attack was never the intention nor the
desire of the person giving it so
recognizing the many types of ways that
critique occurs um even in good faith
environments i think is is valuable yes
and there is
you know i quite like the point you make
about
the difference between differences
between male and female being of a
fundamentally different kind than the
differences between people from
different cultures right
to the extent that you're
correct and i think you are correct that
female kinds of jockeying involve more
cov covert
mechanisms
at the point that we start intermingling
in a space where
high quality critique is extremely
valuable it may be misread in other
words it may be understood to not be
literal but to be uh you know a subtle
attempt to undermine or something like
that and that's a recipe for disaster
right you're either in an environment
where critique is understood to be
highly valuable or it's a weaponized
environment where critique is used
to
to destabilize someone and you've got to
know which one of those you're in in
order to even interpret what you're
hearing
true i don't so
a person could hear what you just said
and map on um
those two things to male female and i
would say that's absolutely not not
correct and i don't think that's what
you meant to say that the idea that
critique is weaponization is a female um
well i would say about things that would
be a covert mechanism yes but it's one
of very many there it is right it's
hardly true that uh the ways that women
engage in critique is inherently
weaponized no i'm not i'm not saying
that but what i am saying is that if you
are going to avail yourself of um
of
covert mechanisms for jockeying
then critique that is not what it
appears to be is one and you know in an
environment you know let's say
a scientific environment
uh you know it's one thing between labs
but within lab for example you want to
have very high quality critique coming
from people who in the end have an
interest in you succeeding and and
frankly that is direct and in fact so i
haven't talked about it extensively
because it's not out yet but i've got a
you know a scientific article coming out
on exactly this as you know um that's
been sort of impressed forever
exactly positing that um we in fact in
you know in some situations that have
been traditionally male
like science like business
uh the more male typical style of of
critique
which is overt
is likely to be the one that we need to
default to
so that i'll just i'll just asterisk
that and we'll come back to it once that
paper is out and i can share it
and talk more about it but we wanted um
we wanted to uh do a tiny little compare
and contrast between two pieces of
criticism our book has received right
um so we've got both a um
a a careful analytical
a careful analytical review on amazon
that's two stars and um you know we
disagree but it's it's careful and we'll
talk about that second and then we have
a review a review i'm gonna put it in
quotes in the guardian um in which the
reviewer appears to have no background
in or interest in actual scientific
thinking and let me preface this by
saying
actually being having no background in
science you know effectively being
scientifically illiterate is totally
fine you know we're all born with
scientific
uh capabilities to some degree with like
a an interest in exploring what the
world is and for most of us uh we don't
get exposed to uh how to think carefully
scientifically in school or it even
actually you know kills that instinct
off in us and so the fact that most
people most adults are walking around
without really a sense of what science
is and how it operates
isn't damning and it's unfortunately
true i wish it weren't but it is
but what is
what is concerning is how many people
think that they're being scientific and
are actually utterly resistant to any
kind of scientific thinking
and um you know part part of the blame
here goes to uh the way that social
science has evolved over the last 20 or
30 years right that this sort of social
constructionist view of humanity has
become dominant in sociology and
anthropology and psychology and in
pretty much all the social sciences
and with that has come a complete
misunderstanding of what an evolutionary
framework is and would do
and so people who engage in social
construction as thinking often imagine
that they're doing something careful but
um but but they're not
so
one way that we can see that we're not
engaging with with criticism of a
scientific
um
of a scientific sort is
um when we could see that the conclusion
had a wrought was arrived at before the
actual review was written and when the
review was not actually about the thing
that it's supposedly reviewing so here's
just one quote from this guardian review
hing and weinstein's advocacy of the
still unproven labley hypothesis gel
nicely with the don't play god mind the
unforeseen consequences stick to the
traditional world view that the book
promotes
so i would just say two points to this
before um you say what you want to say
about it brett um the idea that that
this reviewer is bringing up lab leak or
anything about covet at all is
points to exactly
what i'm saying you know this isn't a
book about coven it was in fact the
first draft was finished
you know before covet was a thing
and
the idea that that has a place in a
review that's supposedly about a book
tells us right away that this isn't what
it appears it's not a book review
and um then the stick to
the idea that this is a stick to the
traditional world view that this book is
promoting
um is you know suggests either the
reviewer did not in fact read the book
which is quite possible or that he is
willfully either misunderstanding
or at least misrepresenting what he does
understand to be the case because we are
quite explicitly not arguing for a
traditional
worldview
and we say it over and over and over
again so this is either sloppy or
anti-scientific or
it's uh
it reflects a conclusion that was
arrived at long before the book was
written which means that this is not a
person who should have been put in
charge of reviewing such a book well i
think actually
i read the review and i think it implies
something even more troubling if a bit
subtle and common
what it implies is that this person is a
verificationist
right because what our book argues very
clearly and explicitly
across the entire thing is we cannot go
back
we have to go forward that is dangerous
and we must figure out what that we
bring with us from the past is still
relevant and useful and what has to be
replaced now the problem is
if you are
a a person a traditionalist and a
verificationist you will find
conservatism in our book if you are a
progressive and an advocate for
a different and better world you will
find radicalism in our book and the idea
that one has to balance these things is
really what the book is about right
but
somebody who's out to uh to deliver a
negative review and this person uh
clearly is a few clicks reveal that they
actually have this position and either
the guardian knew they were sourcing
somebody who would deliver a scathing
review or they didn't know and should
have but either way that's what they did
but in any case a verificationist going
through the book and finding reason to
dismiss it on the basis that you know it
is a it is
about some sort of a conservative
traditional world view tells you that
they if they read it they you know they
got half of it um
but the other thing is what a
fascinating week
to deploy this trope about the lab
league right because the lab leak as
much as people had realized that it was
uh extremely likely as of you know john
stewart's beginning to mock it as he
did took another leap you know the
remainder of the distance uh was largely
covered by the discovery that there had
been a grant proposal to induce to
introduce exactly the foreign site that
we find in sars kovi ii uh
that had been delivered by eco health
alliance and peter dasik so we know that
this exact change had been proposed now
that grant proposal was rejected but it
doesn't matter the point is
what a week to just press that button oh
loudly conspiracy theory when in fact uh
all the reasonable people have realized
that it was you know it was never a
dismissable conspiracy theory it was
always viable and there's an awful lot
of evidence for it well it seems to me
there's an analogy here um that not only
is a lot of sort of you know this
this person who i imagine is sort of
immersed in woke world and in social
constructionist world um so much of that
world is actually biologically
essentialist in a way that an actual
understanding of human evolution would
not support
and similarly this so-called progressive
world is actually highly reliant on
authorities and institutions that are
pretending to speak truth but actually
coming to conclusions behind closed
doors and never showing us the analysis
and so you know part of part of what
we're we're doing you know we've we've
been doing for a while now on this show
is um
you know not so much in the last couple
of months we've been focused on the book
but um looking at analyses and assessing
whether or not those analyses make sense
and part of the reason
that we find ourselves out of step with
some of what is being promoted as public
health policy right now is that almost
nothing that has emerged during this
pandemic from public health officials or
the cdc who whatever
comes with a description of the analysis
that was done
sometimes there are
some references to data sets but the
actual analysis is alighted it is hidden
it is obscured which is exactly
antithetical to science
not just the results of science need to
be in public view but the actual
scientific process and so the analyses
that we've been relying on as we come to
conclusions that are wildly out of step
sometimes with uh what some public
health officials would say
are exactly that their analyses in which
we can actually look at and assess the
analyses done so that's that's what
scientists do right that's what
scientists do and you know you make the
point
that um
the review can't start with its
conclusion it's not a valid review and
you can say the exact same thing about
science i don't care
how sophisticated your you know
measurement apparatus was i don't care
how fancy the laboratory i don't care
what degree you have if you started with
a conclusion and worked backwards from
it it's not only not science it's the
opposite of science right a review that
starts with its conclusion isn't a
review yeah right well you know a review
you know you could you could imagine a
review that's written which is which
did not begin the book
with the conclusion but now that they're
writing it um they've come to the
conclusion but so you know a reviewer
who approaches the book that they are
supposed to be reviewing already with
their conclusion in their head is not
capable of writing a review the process
of review yeah right you have to be open
to the possibility that there's
something there before you declare that
it's absent that's right so let's just
talk a little bit about this um
um the
this two-star review on amazon by a guy
named ryan wassuno whose name i'm
unfortunately probably um butchering
here
uh let me see if i can pull it up uh
here we go should we show it or why not
okay so i should just say so you can
show the sack you know we were watching
the the book go live and reviews show up
and
uh someone called our attention to this
review it was the first negative review
and i went and read it and i thought
actually
it's wrong i think i know why it's wrong
but
the person did an honest
they made an honest attempt at
evaluating it they reached a conclusion
that i think is actually very much the
beginning of an important discussion
this is what a review of the book should
look like that is negative right so
obviously we disagree because if we
didn't we wouldn't have written the book
that we did right so uh you know we have
we have lots of reviews um
you know we have
many many i can't okay sorry guys um uh
we've we've many many reviews that are
that are uh positive and careful and
reflective of what's in the book and
there's one negative review that feels
to us like what a negative review should
sound like so let's talk about so he
basically he basically disagrees and you
can take my screen off now zach
the title of view is culture does not
exist to serve the genome
which is him pushing back against the
one of the
theoretical concepts that we introduce
in the book right this is not already
out there in the scientific literature
this is new with us
which we introduced in the first chapter
which is the omega principle and
you know
we we can understand why you might not
agree with the omega principle but as we
have argued elsewhere
if you don't you have to explain then
what culture is
and if you're simply black boxing
culture and saying it can't possibly be
evolutionary can't possibly be serving
genetic ends
then you you are taking it on faith
that's basically a faith-rich argument
so
we should say what it is yeah so the
omega principle is a two-part principle
basically it we choose omega because
it's a greek letter it's supposed to
evoke pi which specifies the precise
relationship between the diameter and
circumference of a circle and likewise
omega specifies what we say is the
precise relationship the obligate
relationship between culture and other
epigenetic phenomenon on the one hand
phenomena on the one hand and the genome
on the other
and the relationship is epigenetic
phenomena evolve more rapidly they're
more adaptable
but they are obligated to the objectives
of the genome that is they serve the
genome's ends
and this is indeed a very provocative
claim now
i will
say something even more provocative here
which is that
of course you would get some pushback on
this right because the implications of
this principle are so profound that they
really change everything
you know for most creatures it doesn't
change your evolutionary analysis it
doesn't have almost anything to say
about
you know well at least as far as culture
goes obviously doesn't have anything to
say about plants or fungi or most
animals
but
as you get to humans it changes
everything about the meaning of what we
are and how we ended up this way and so
if we are incorrect about this
it actually renders a huge amount of the
analysis that we do in the book wrong
but we are not incorrect we show our
work and i don't actually even think
that's true i i was expecting a little
pushback but
um the reason that it is because because
there's so much else in the book um that
is consistent with you know mismatch
hypothesis or um scientism as replacing
scientific thinking or reductionism and
over reliance on metrics all with all of
which are you know
i
everything that we do
um
is consistent with one or more of those
but there's plenty um that doesn't
actually rely on omega although omega is
consistent with everything that we talk
about in the book no i would say it
differently i would say there are many
things in the book that are
true irrespective of omega but that the
central idea right
is predicated on the basis that our
uh our apparatus for generating culture
the conscious apparatus that then
generates culture is consistent with an
evolutionary analysis that it is not the
cultural layer in conflict with the
genetic layer it may be that our ancient
culture is out of step with our current
environment but it is not that our
culture is out of step with our genome
yeah no i i see this so you know
mismatch hypothesis which has been
discussed by many many people um might
be absent an understanding of omega
principle
be imagined to be this is just you know
this is just the derangement that
modernity brings us because you know
culture and we are trying to to explain
something more consistently more deeply
by saying well yes you know culture but
culture is itself at least that culture
which is
long long-standing and expensive to
maintain or create and uh variable and
extent is itself inherently an
adaptation right so
um
the the point is this principle is going
to end up being right and the reason
that we know it's going to end up being
right is that the logic that explains
why it has to be right is actually not
complex at all right the fact is a
cultural brain is the product of a
genome which puts the genes in a perfect
position to shut it down if it isn't
serving the genome's ends and what
people the step people miss is it's
impossible for cultural stuff to be cost
free right cultural stuff that has you
doing something is wasting the time and
energy of the genome
cultural stuff that forbids you from
doing something is limiting
opportunities so these things are costly
to the genome and therefore for the
genome to have facilitated a mind that
gets filled with this stuff it has to
have on average paid yeah right so
um
that said once you get
to that step right this is something
1976 dawkins introduces memetic
evolution
he
uh it's a brilliant introduction but he
makes what we claim is an error he says
culture is a new prime evil soup it's
basically a new tree of life cultural
phenomena evolve he argues correctly but
he's arguing that they are evolving
independent of the layer that they they
ride on top of and
were that true it describes a whole a
very complex and in fact
a landscape that can't even really be
analyzed because many things hover
between layers right yeah language has
both phenomena and it has purely
cultural stuff and it has a you know
genetic underpinning what do you make of
that evolutionarily if these two things
are independent on the other hand if
they're both serving genetic ends then
you can analyze this and the point is
whoa a whole bunch of stuff that is
paradoxical if we treat it as
independent of the genome is no longer
paradoxical it becomes tractable if we
approach these things with this uh this
assumption yeah
um i'm reminded so we have a section at
the very end recommended further reading
where we recommend a couple of books um
unrelated to our own work uh that we
have learned from and that speak to some
of the issues in that chapter and so at
the very end we say more technical texts
that are nonetheless excellent include
one of the two here is this jablonka and
lam text and i would have pulled up the
book but it's not in this room right now
uh from 2014 called evolution in four
dimensions genetic epigenetic behavioral
and symbolic variation in the history of
life this is an extraordinary book it's
super dense um you know it's not easy
going um even for us i once i once tried
to just give us sort of a page long
excerpt to freshmen um and it didn't it
didn't go over too well you know
advanced advanced undergraduates would
have been different but it's just it's
it's dense i'll warn you but it's truly
a terrific book
um and
you know but the title genetic
epigenetic behavioral and symbolic uh
something something in the evolution of
life um suggests that they are
would seem to imply that these are
different things and so i'm sorry if i
missed it but i think one thing you
didn't say in your description of
omega principle this time
is that um we are talking about genetic
phenomena and everyone has a pretty
decent model of what that means and then
epigenetic phenomena and epigenetic just
means above the genome
and
back when we were in grad school it
actually was used in this sensu lata way
this broad way
to mean anything that was above the
level of the genome that could impact
the genome
and then in modern times most people
including many biologists but certainly
most non-biologists when they hear
epigenetic they assume that what you're
talking about is molecular mechanisms
which is a very sensu a very narrow
sense of what epigenetic might mean so
things like dna methylation
and what we argue is um that we have uh
circumscribed our understanding of
epigenetics to our peril that there are
things like culture that are epigenetic
censulato
that are
just as um just as much downstream of
genetics and also ultimately serving
genetic ends so not only uh downstream
but the shocking thing the part that
still surprises me is that actually the
analogy between something like culture
and something like these molecular
mechanisms that regulate gene expression
actually do belong very much in the same
category because they do the same thing
right so if you think about it uh for
those of you who are not experienced
with it
these molecular mechanisms regulate
which genes get expressed where and so
you have
when
right where and when so the fact that
your eyes and your your eye cells and
your liver cells look very different
despite having the same genome is the
result of the fact that there are these
um some degree how to actually sorry
right but yeah
anyway it allows you to be a complex
organism rather than just a puddle of
like cells right and so that's good for
most of us it's pretty darn great yeah
and so enjoying it so you know imagine
that we we recently
uh figured out this landscape enough to
begin talking about how that process
works so this is the last several
decades
and you can imagine that there would be
a lot of excitement about that because
you know a single genome
doesn't an organism make but uh but the
separate regulation allows all sorts of
things
to to unfold i mean including
two genomes that are alike but express
one as a male and one as a female right
these are all epigenetically regulated
phenomena
but that excitement about what the
epigenetic regulators of genes
do obscures this other thing which is
specifically relevant to humans and the
point is culture regulates the
expression of genes too right it
regulates the fact that your body will
be in church on sunday morning or you
know
not right those sorts of things so the
point is it's still shaping the way the
genome is expressed in the world which
is why it subscribes to the same rule
um okay go ahead uh well slight slight
pivot um i was just you know i'm i'm
very interested and and we're going to
talk a little bit about some of the you
know we continue to do lots of
interviews you know sometimes multiple
ones a day and it's going to continue on
um
into the future uh which for which we
are grateful um although it's it's super
fascinating to see how different the
approach of say professional scientists
is when they talk to us about the book
as opposed to people with um audiences
um that don't at least understand
themselves to be scientific at all
and uh one of the uh one of the places
where uh this happened to just be me
was interviewed was on the gym rat
podcast and we talked about this a
little bit last week but i was
particularly taken with um this quote
from his show notes just to reflect and
this is not his description of our book
but his description of his and my
conversation about the book
and this is of course not a complete
list but
in his show notes for the show that he
and i did together and again jim is
himself a scientist
yes
yeah he's a complexity scientist i mean
not by degree but by yeah
professional history yeah former uh head
of the santa fe institute etc uh quote
they meaning jim and me discuss hyper
novelty and its challenges niche
switching is the human niche the
naturalistic fallacy the ancient
baringians entry into the americas the
hubris of reductionism and
neocornucopianism
humans as the blankest slates
metaphorical and literal campfires
scaling laws and social groups theory of
mind social media's flattening effects
including flattened affects social media
sabbaticals the suckers folly something
we introduce in the book human
population explosion the personal
responsibility vortex which is from an
earlier ted talk of yours brett proto b
communities the lineage view of
evolution understanding exponentials and
fatal events culture as evolutionary
adaptation the omega principle again
something we introduced in the book
humanity's fourth frontier again
something we introduced in the book so
um that's
you know i i just love that list it's an
accurate and yet still not complete list
of the conversation that jim and i had
and it's certainly not a complete um
telling of what it is that we cover in
this book and so you know part of
part of the challenge for people who
would hate on us
and this book
is that um it's really really hard to
pigeonhole us
and uh the idea that
the book is filled with pseudoscience
because we have ideas in it
that haven't been vetted by other people
well that is of course what science does
so
i noticed another kind of critique
coming back at us which i want to point
to which i think is actually in its own
way a very positive indication in a
number of different places on twitter
and on reddit i encountered criticisms
about all sorts of things that people
claim uh
we don't talk about and it's a critical
failure of the book like genetic drift
founder effects
um genetic sweeps
and i pointed out we also didn't include
punnett squares right but but i would
point out that this is an echo of a
long-standing battle in evolutionary
biology that you and i have been part of
for decades it's not like we're unaware
of genetic drift but
the basic thing you need to understand
to know what this is about is the so
evolution is defined as the change in
gene frequency in a population over time
that's evolution
almost always when people invoke
evolution they mean adaptation which is
something different it's one of four
mechanisms of evolution
right and so
what they are effectively and the the
thing that you need to understand is
that almost all evolutionary change
heather is closing the window because
somebody is uh i don't know
tearing up the street or something like
that
um almost all evolutionary change is
non-adaptive right it is mostly
the result of drift and these other
lesser mechanisms uh migration and
mutation now all
adaptation ultimately traces back to
mutations that then got favored by
selection but the basic point is almost
all evolution is not adaptive almost
everything that matters is in that tiny
subset that is adaptive right and so
this critique is like a lashing about
yeah well i mean it's a sorry bag
it's it's the same old same old like i
have i almost have less patience for
this one um because it's
you know the driftists as as some in
evolutionary biology would call those
who see drift as majorly explanatory um
drift being the random element in
evolution that is if you happened to be
walking under the window when the piano
fell out in the middle then um then uh
then that then your death is due to
drift as opposed to you were helping
like you were somehow involved there um
as a feature of the piano being there
and you died and then that would be
selection
randomness doesn't build complexity yeah
that you know that's that that's the
argument at its base that's all it takes
right drift is the random element in
evolution mutation is the origin of all
change flow gene flow is just the
movement between populations which is
utterly important but you know the four
mechanisms of microevolution mutation
origin of all variation drift the random
element flow the movement between
populations and selection
selection is that which builds
complexity and so is it more rare than
drift sure but it builds complexity and
randomness can't right i can't do it and
you know
we could go on at length about this but
the reason that i i'm focused on this is
that at some at the point that multiple
people are leveling this criticism right
what it tells you is they don't have
anything else right it's pretty empty
and yeah i i had one delightful
experience i have to relate to okay
so i saw one of these criticisms
somebody on reddit specifically uh took
us to task in the book for not dealing
with genetic sweep founder effects and
uh drift and i pointed out in a reply
that in fact though these terms are not
mentioned in there i gave an example of
each phenomenon and i basically said
look this is
not important because it isn't relevant
to the subject matter of the book
and the person
responded by accusing me of not having
read the book
which i'd say you're not showing up as
yourself somehow
if if you knew enough about us you
probably could have figured out it was
me but the basic nature of read it is
that people's names aren't their names
and um so anyway yes i i thought that
was lovely and i should have
screenshotted it yes you should have
that one should have gone on my wall
yeah but uh somebody then alerted him to
who he was talking to and he he uh
edited it but okay anyway
well that is that's that's funny yeah
that
soon we'll start seeing that critique
you haven't even read your own weight
who wrote it then okay
um
so i guess i want to just sort of
cap this off by saying um that if you're
scientifically uninterested
especially if you are also unshakable in
what turns out to be a scientifically
incoherent ideology such as wokeness or
trust the authorities are book's gonna
be a threat
to you and it's not meant to be a threat
to anyone it's meant to be a you know a
way you know to some degree a guidebook
although it also does dive deep and
introduces several new evolutionary
concepts while also bringing people up
to speed on several um things that we
know to be true in evolution that were
you know other people's contributions
um
it's meant to bring everyone in on the
conversation about what it is to be
human and how best to move forward um
it's not a threat to actual scientists
nor is it a threat to those without
scientific background who are eager to
learn so again it's not that if you're
if you happen to be scientifically
illiterate you don't you can't go here
with us of course you can so i'm
reminded of
um an interaction we had with our our
wonderful editor um shortly after we
signed the book and we really didn't
know her at all
um we signed the contract for the book a
couple years ago and she said uh who is
your intended audience
and i said everyone
and i think she thought i was kidding um
but i don't i actually haven't asked
helen this um but i doubt she does now
because what i said to her was look um
certainly um you know us teaching at a
uh not
prestigious college still didn't get us
access to all of what humanity has
although we've also traveled widely
enough and interacted with so many so
many types of people
but
in our classrooms we reached across
differences that were far greater than
you would expect to see in most college
classrooms
and we found our common humanity there
and we found that people who came in
even people who came in as creationists
who came in specifically seeking
to be armed against
our kinds of ways of approaching the
world
found things to um to embrace and to
honor and to speak to
in an evolutionary world view so you
know this is this is exactly what
we found ourselves doing uh for for 15
years in classrooms and it's not you
know it's the evolutionary worldview and
an understanding of humanity and other
organisms that is what you and i are
driven by much more deeply but because
we had this what turns out to have been
an interlude
of 15 years really learning how to
educate and how to to reach people who
don't look or sound like us or believe
the same things we do or have the same
developmental histories
we feel like not only does do all people
deserve
this kind of evolutionary toolkit but
they are capable of receiving it so
i was thinking a little bit about the
taxonomy of
people who
don't accept things like the omega
principle and you know the point is it
has to be proposed and you have to
decide whether to accept it but we we
get several different kinds of
resistance right i i see three kinds
that we've encountered
one has to do
with people who believe that you
shouldn't analyze human
behavior and culture with these tools
not that it doesn't work but that it's
too dangerous right now i am
stunned by this dawkins when i met with
him in october of 2018
in chicago i think it was 2018.
in any case
whenever that may have been
um
espoused this perspective that he
thought there was something dangerous
about looking at human history through
the lens of evolution which shocked me
right seemed to me that he had switched
positions uh from where he would have
been in his previous incarnation but
nonetheless there's an awful lot that's
that's common among actually smart
evolutionary biologists i've heard i'm
not going to name other names here but
i've heard it a lot right but it's also
it was uh
the motivating force it appears behind
gould and lewinton and all sorts of
people who were on the other side of the
question of adaptation or as that is
dismissed adaptationism
right so there was effectively a group
of scientists who sought to and were
successful in many regards in derailing
the
evolutionary analysis of people so in
the aftermath of
sociobiology being coined as a term
there was this pushback right and it was
disguised in many regards as this
doesn't work but really what it was is
that's not a good idea
um
there are some questions you should not
ask right yep um
the second group i would say are a group
of people who are confused about whether
or not this is true information stops at
the neck people well i don't want to
dismiss them that way i think you
shouldn't accept omega until you see why
it has to be right at which point you
know the burden of proof is on those of
us who believe in something like omega
yes until you've met that burden you
shouldn't accept it and then once you
see it hopefully the burden shifts um
but anyway i respect this group and i i
see it as our obligation to convince
them of why this is an important thing
to understand and what it does to the
understanding of people downstream of it
but the third group the one that
troubles me most
are
people who are threatened
in a career sense
by the exploration of human beings as an
evolutionary phenomenon so for example
people in the humanities right
more likely people in social sciences
i would say actually we see it in both
but you know if you look at for example
just by these these modern
bastardizations of fields that actually
should have a tremendous amount to offer
well i think they do potentially have a
tremendous amount to offer the problem
is what the
nominal field has to offer and the
incentives of the individuals in it are
quite different and so if you look at
something like the reaction
that uh
historians had to guns germs and steel
right um it was very very negative but
when you look at the quality of the
critique
it's not about the fact that it doesn't
work it's about its territoriality yeah
right and so the idea that you know it
if you're going to do
cultural anthropology right and you
don't want to have to do an analysis
that
deals with adaptation as a phenomenon
you just simply want to you know zoom in
and look at cultures and compare them
and imagine that you're not looking at a
biological phenomenon right then you
need omega not to be right right it's
stay in your lane-ism as a form of
social territoriality it and it's
in a in an environment in which the
market
causes this to emerge because people who
are not going to be able to participate
in that discussion nonetheless want to
hold their position within the fields
and so these fields pretend that what
they're doing is not impacted by
evolutionary dynamics
as a matter of uh you know which means
you have to build all sorts of epic
cycles and you know like the
evolutionary view is clarifying and once
you know it you can also figure out
better you have a better chance of
figuring out how to avoid and evade the
reprehensible parts of what our
evolution has made us prone to right
that's that's the best way to make
ourselves better is to know what it is
that we have inherited from the past
right and you know to the extent that
you believe that something like uh
cultural evolution
or
a study of cultures has a lot to offer
right you want the most powerful tools
with which to analyze it so you
understand what it means rather than
just uh
being a purely descriptive phenomenon
yeah and so you know and you know we the
public pay for
fields to study things right we
subsidize this work and so the question
is are we getting what we uh have paid
for and we will get it much more
successfully if we accept that there are
simplifying rubrics that actually unite
this into one story rather than making
all of these things separate
okay um
uh
i guess i would finish by saying and
recognize that we are like or almost
supposedly done and we have only gotten
to a tiny bit of what we were hoping to
get to today
um
i would say that our book is an
invitation to think deeply about what we
are and how to live better with um
live better lives of both the individual
and the societal level like quite
explicitly that's what it is so if you
reject that goal out of hand i
wonder what your goal is like what is it
that you are serving and what is it that
you are trying to achieve
um you you know you may disagree with us
as the one review that we um discuss
does and i think your your taxonomy of
the three the three
types of ways that you come to
disagreement with something like the
omega principle uh is apt i like that
um so i wanted also to
say here before we move on to talking
about this new this new research out of
uh uh
new mexico really um with regard to the
peopleing of the americas
um
is that we um most of this stuff isn't
out yet but um we did some more
interviews this week that were so varied
um in how they came across that uh
it's just worth mentioning so um we were
on coast to coast am uh which uh is is
apparently uh the longest running radio
show
out there
um and uh it's very much not a science
show um
uh you know we got we got pushback on on
religion
we talked about the realignment
uh no not we talked about we were on the
realignment i was trying to understand
are you sending me a message
um
we were on the realignment with host
sagar and jetty and marshall kosloff i
hope i'm pronouncing marshall's last
name correctly which was largely a
political discussion but we had in there
a really nice dive actually into
some of what
many people who i think have been
trained in social sciences and
humanities even just at the at the
college level
imagine a darwinian approach to human
behavior would provide us and so we're
in that conversation we talk about uh
why it is that this is not an invitation
to social darwinism this is not an
invitation to go backwards and it's not
an invitation uh to pursue our our worst
angels at all quite the opposite
uh we
talked with brian keating
with into the impossible which he
describes as a podcast of stories ideas
and speculations from the arthur c
clarke center for human human
imagination he's an astrophysicist and
the distinguished professor of physics
at uc san diego so that
in that conversation we got to finally
talk a little bit about aliens too which
i thought was fun and then sounds of
film with tom needham uh different feel
entirely he's um the show has been on
the air for 30 years and you've been on
it before um but we we were able to talk
in just such a very different way so
i
i'm just thrilled to be able to be
having the diversity of conversations
we're having it's not just with
scientists and it's not just not with
scientists and it's not just with people
who come from a religious perspective or
not uh it's it's across the board
and so in service of that before we talk
about the uh evidence of humans in north
america during the last glacial maximum
did you want to say a few things about
the anomalies that we've been seeing
with regard to the availability of the
book before we sort of move on beyond
talking about this yeah this book here's
our here's our one copy here's the copy
we've got i just wanna um
i i we don't know what to make of the
weird there is obviously a supply chain
issue but we also know that tens of
thousands of books have been printed and
uh
and
presumably delivered to retailers and we
see
amazon oscillating for example between
uh temporarily out of stock and briefly
it said in stock soon with a delivery
date in november and now it's back to
temporarily out of stock right so we
don't know what to make of it but
uh
we
would ask people to just if you are
looking for it uh either order it and it
will come hopefully sooner than those
projections or
it's available on
barnes and noble still your places
like you know we forgot to say at the
very start like we made the new york
times bestseller list
this is true yeah and it just feels
amazing and you know we're the second um
highest selling book in nonfiction on
amazon last week that's sure not to be
the case this week because they
literally haven't had any copies to sell
right the entire week they haven't had
any copies since the third day after
publication
um which is you know it
it feels good but it also feels
frustrating and so if you if you want if
you want the book and you don't have it
barnes and noble does still have it
all right
we have
this paper this year that came out
zachary if you would show my screen um
evidence this is bennett at all in
science evidence of humans in north
america during the last glacial maximum
and actually take my screen off for a
moment because i'm not logged in there
but i'm going to pull up the pdf so we
can show
um the amazing pictures
some of the amazing pictures and some of
what i've seen so here you can show my
screen again
this is uh again published in science
this week evidence of humans in north
america during the last glacial maximum
they are finding because what they've
done is they found footprints
in modern day new mexico that they can
date to 23 000 years ago ish
and as they say here
and what i've got highlighted uh fossil
human footprints provide an alternative
source of evidence for human presence
unlike cultural artifacts modified bones
or other more conventional fossils
footprints have a primary depositional
context are fixed on the imprinted
surface all of that is science speak for
actually we can date footprints with
greater accuracy and precision
than we can date many other types of
evidence
so i must say this is a million miles
from either of our specialty
i do wonder right so that the history is
that we have a
earliest date on which we all agree for
the presence of humans in north america
right the clovis people
um and then you don't mean early
we have a farthest back in time date on
which we all agree it goes back at least
this far
at least this far and then there are all
of these claims about evidence that go
farther back and these claims are very
contentious some of them are stronger
than others some of them are clearly
nonsense well we i mean we actually
opened the book like the very first
chapter right it goes into the
beringians and the people in the
americas and we you know we
say that we tend towards this these
earlier dates
um but a conservative estimate is
sometime between 10 and 30 000 years
that's a huge span sometime between 10
and 30 30 000 years ago
uh the americas uh were peopled for the
first time but uh we have
the evidence to our eyes has looked even
before this like more than 20 000 years
ago seems much more likely right and i
should say there are some other remote
contingencies which we should get rid of
like there's the possibility that human
beings
landed in
in the americas went extinct and so that
could be true and have no implication
whatsoever for the peopling of the
americas that matters from the point of
view of all of the native cultures that
were here
um so anyway that's a possibility
there's also some some people are still
arguing uh for crossing the pacific
right as opposed to going through what
is now submerged uh under the bering
strait but beringia as a land mass that
was uh that was a land mass for several
thousand years right nonetheless uh so i
do wonder about the security of the
evidence here right so it's possible
that it's as secure as they're claiming
but it's also true that there are
various processes that can confuse you
right so um these
there's a process for example called
reworking right there are certain things
like clams that will actually take
uh material and
in their excavation for their clambros
will move it around and so they can put
things in a strata that it doesn't
belong in right but having a 2d having a
widow's effectively parietal um and that
that is not itself disrupted by um such
possible workings
this this depositional site has not been
reworked but what i want to know but
again you know we are outside it may be
that these folks know exactly what
they're doing and they've ruled out
every possibility but imagine for
example that footprints had been very
very shallow
and that they had caused a difference in
water to accumulate in versus outside of
in other words water would run off the
substrate where there was no footprint
and where there was a footprint you
would get extra erosion
because of a positive feedback could it
work could a footprint work its way down
into strata that weren't where it was uh
where it was made
i don't know hopefully these people have
ruled that out but yeah really far
outside anything that we have done
directly but sort of i think you are
proposing a process a little bit like
um
the fossilization of wood
or you know fossilization at all some
level just you know replacement of the
original
the original material just that a
physical process could move
you know these are not going to be
carbon dated right these are going to be
dated by the strata in which the
footprint is made which seems to be
unambiguous but i read it but i don't
remember what exactly the
methods are here i don't remember but
anyway
there's what you want this is first of
all if this is true
for there to have been footprints 23 000
years ago in the americas nails down
even if you never found another shred of
evidence for it the point is if those
footprints really are that old then it
says there were people to make those
footprints then so the point is you want
to be really sure that there is nothing
that could conceivably have misled you
about how old those footprints were
before you decide well they were here 23
000 years ago and that's just a simple
fact so anyway we'll see whether the the
result holds up but if it does it has
many many implications right one of
which is let me just read another little
tiny bit from the paper
uh ich no fossils of extinct late
pleistocene fauna occur widely on the
margins of the playa and include tracks
of propositiona mammoth
falibra ground sloth carnivora both
canid and phelid and cedardiodactyl
bovid and kamelid most of which are
associated with human footprints so
we've got mammoths ground sloths uh wild
dogs and cats of unspecified species and
both um cowish things and camellids
uh present in the same place as
as the footprints which charismatic
megafauna all
this puts humans
there at the same time as they were
abundant which provides further evidence
potentially for the idea that we helped
hasten their extinctions well actually i
was wondering about whether it doesn't
do exactly the opposite
um because so if 23 000 years is a good
date
then human beings were not facing the
retreating ice sheets they skirted under
them or came across by ship well this
well not you're not arguing across by
ship you're talking about coastal route
down by skin well i think that's no no i
i'm
leaving open the remote possibility of
some other introductory mechanism from
asia ship seems like a strange word here
boat okay um but the point is
the model the easiest model is there
were people living in beringia which
there were and that that population as
the waters rose
moved right and that some of them ended
up in north america if 23 000 years is
the date then it may be that earlier
because new mexico isn't um you know
olympia right but it could be you know
it could take 50 years to go that
distance there's not inherently a reason
for people to move that fast but it but
the point is moving during uh the
glaciated period is certainly possible
it suggests certain routes and not
others right it narrows down the likely
mode of passage
and it puts people
in north america
not at exactly the moment of the
elimination of many of these megafauna
if i understand it correctly and so one
of the pieces of evidence that people
point to with respect to the human over
hunting hypothesis which to me is very
plausible because these animals would
have had no experience with human
hunting and therefore would have behaved
the way we see creatures behave in the
galapagos where they don't run away from
you for example right they would have
been easy prey and therefore easily
hunted out
but i believe this would interface with
that
and suggest that it isn't such a tight
correlation in time i'd like to know
better whether or not that's yeah i
think um
the strongest evidence that i've seen
against the uh extinction of the north
american megaphone charismatic megafauna
not being due to humans has been that uh
at least clovis first suggested if i've
got my dates right uh that humans
basically showed up after the extension
said after at least some of the
extensions had already happened or were
already clearly on the decline so it was
sort of like
uh you know pissarro and company arrived
on mayan shores and um yes killed them
off but but the maya were already on
decline in decline at that point
and so this has people
present well before we have any evidence
that the charismatic megafauna
populations were already in decline
suggesting that it is possibly um
our existence here uh is possibly causal
all right interesting we should talk to
some of our paleo friends and see how
this actually plays out indeed now did
you want me to show some of these images
yeah it's worth seeing them i i was
pretty impressed zachary
uh so we're talking about uh modern
modern new mexico of course and here we
have these images of for those only
listening of some of the footprints that
these authors
are are finding and they really are you
know as tends to be the way with
footprints as opposed to a lot of other
kinds of archaeological and um
paleoanthropological
uh evidence
footprints tend to look like footprints
yeah they're really compelling in a way
like parietal art is often very
compelling that is to say things like
cave drawings
but a lot of you know pot shards and
such often is not compelling unless you
already know what you're looking for but
footprints
footprints do something for the for the
sort of the visceral brain and body of
the person of the modern observing them
yes when i uh went to look at the paper
you know i was expecting not to be
terribly convinced by the pictures which
doesn't mean that they're not footprints
but i was expecting to have to take
their word for it that's what they were
and i was like oh yeah exactly yeah i'm
compelled still look like footprints
yeah very much so
um
okay so this um this is
amazing this amazing discovery on the
part of the researchers
and it also represents discovery
of a geographic frontier on the part of
the people
who laid down those footprints
and
we in the book and we've talked about
this previously on on this podcast and
elsewhere and it's in the book talk
about these three types of frontiers
that humans have historically
encountered geographic frontiers
technological frontiers and transfer of
resource frontiers the latter of which
is a form of theft and is
and is immoral
human history though is full of these
moments of of geographic discovery of
you know however it is and whenever it
was that
uh the first uh americans arrived on the
shores of america
um you know be it 10 000 years ago seems
not 20 000 years ago probably not 25 30
000 years ago maybe
uh whenever that was
that was discovery that was you know
there was a moment
at which
people
first set foot on this land mass that
offered two continents worth of of
opportunity
and because geographic discovery tends
to come so early in human history it
doesn't tend to come with texts you know
these aren't people who are writing
things down by and large
we have later people showing up and
thinking they've discovered things who
have writing and who write about those
things but those are transfer of
resource frontiers right you know the
the spaniards coming to the new world
were not engaged in geographic
frontiersism they were engaged in
transfer of resource frontiers and
whether or not they knew that or not
some of them presumably um quickly did
come to know that and many of them
presumably did not columbus discovered
americans
that's that's right yeah exactly
um
so because history the way that history
is taught in history even i i was
shocked when i learned this and
i was well into adulthood when i learned
that actually history understands itself
to be the study of the written texts of
what humans have left behind
and anything before that is called
prehistory well because history is
biased in this way and a bias it is
it's going to vastly underrepresent
geographic frontiers and what happens
when humans um come upon them and and
how they explore in that space and of
course it's part of it's what paleo
anthropologists do and archaeologists
and it's part of what we are doing in
the book and our thinking is trying to
figure out how it is that humans
have engaged in discovery
even as you know at this point in time
there is there is almost nothing left to
be discovered at least on this planet
with regard to geographic frontiers
so
that bias in history because of its bias
on texts will steer us from away from
deep history it'll steer us away from
stories of non-literate people um and as
has often been noted it's going to be
more likely to reflect the tales of the
victors of wars or the otherwise
privileged um for whatever reason that
they were the ones able to tell to tell
their stories not just tell their
stories but write down their stories and
have those written archives make it into
the into the future to say the now i
would just point out that this
interfaces with
the guns terms and steel analysis
because the idea is the cultures that
are likely to win when two cultures come
into conflict are the ones that have
slight advantage by being a few hundred
years ahead technologically speaking and
those are likely to be ones that do have
uh also the capacity to write a
description of what took place precisely
and you know it's one of the reasons um
it's one of the reasons that we've
that what happened to the maya is so
i mean it's always going to be tragic
but it's particularly tragic because
they did have written language and they
did have libraries and it's just extra
we can imagine
that they had extraordinary histories
and um scientific textbooks and i don't
know if they would have called them
textbooks but you know they had
astronomy they had the concept of zero
they had
roads and city-states and politics and
um just extraordinary stuff and
one of the things that the spaniards did
is they destroyed it so we're left
basically with a tiny bit of those
things that were inscribed on pyramids
and we're not left with the library we
have one text
that was written on uh
some other material but the rest of it
was burned that which was flammable was
burned yeah um so and that's you know
that's
that's a transfer resource frontier
right there you know part of what you do
is you destroy the history that comes
before so that um
so as to obscure it well i would i would
just in passing point out that whatever
that instinct is that causes a
population to actually instead of
preserving the the relics of populations
that they have uh
run across to destroy them
right that is some sort of an
evolutionary
lineage against lineage instinct and we
are seeing it we are watching right the
destruction of that's one of the
reprehensible evolutionary instincts
it's a reprehensible evolutionary
instinct that we are seeing within our
own culture right the tearing down of
statues the fact that the
elk statue in portland you know was
successfully removed by crazy people who
you know obviously couldn't possibly
have had a complaint about you know the
abhorrent views of elk because they
don't presumably have any abhorrent
views you may underestimate the people
and their views on the important views
of elk they've yes but in any case the
point is the instinct to be tearing down
statues of
lincoln and whatever elk happened to be
memorialized in your city and all of
that um is this ancient instinct to
destroy something as you take power and
overwrite the prior history so we should
be aware it's unfolding and we can you
know you can zoom in too close and think
it's about something that it really
isn't yes absolutely so um
you know so so many places we could go
here but i guess one of one of the
things that i wanted to get to was to
say that actually zachary our our
producer here our older son has had
several extraordinary history teachers
and i want to point out that um
that what i'm about to say is not true
of all of the ways that history is being
taught now but
um
but we also know of more than one high
school history class for instance we've
heard tell
where the focus is entirely on that
third type of frontier that we just
talked about so not on geographic
frontiers for this sort of reason this
bias that's built into history where it
doesn't talk about those things which
haven't been written down but also not
on technological frontiers wherein
humans with their ingenuity make more of
some resource than what was possible
before the technological innovation but
instead of focus entirely on these
transfer of resource frontiers which are
not a legitimate form of frontier they
are theft and certainly it has happened
a lot there has been a lot of land theft
for instance in in human history
um but
rather than exploring the diversity of
types of frontiers that humans have
engaged in or
we're talking about how technological
innovation for instance has allowed
people to make to make systems that are
functional for some period of time
instead we have increasingly with the
ideology that is spreading in modern
history classrooms many of them not all
of them a focus entirely on on theft and
i know you want to talk a little bit
about um
exactly a form of theft that seems to be
happening right now but be at land theft
or resource after people theft in the
form of
slavery um it's a real part of human
history to be sure but it's it's not the
only part
and um also this excuse is nothing but
very often the people who were being
robbed of their land
um
had themselves dispatched whoever came
before them
and so you know we have this
this sort of noble savage
um view of people who came before and
who had their land stolen from them uh
and the people who were doing the
stealing are super villains and the
people who had the land stolen from them
are somehow um were somehow perfect and
frankly that's a
fairly racist view of those people as
well
every civilization that has left a mark
has engaged in some combination of
cooperation and competition this again
is a theme of the book right every
single one of us and every single
civilization has left any sort of mark
uh has engaged in both of these things
cooperation and competition are some
civilizations more brutal than others
for sure and some less but pretending
that land theft or resource theft or
people theft is the only thing worth
talking about in human history
that's that is both a sign of your own
privilege to be able to talk about that
to the exclusion of all of the wondrous
things that humans have done
but it also creates in children the
children who are receiving these lessons
a sense of futility you know it's
actually a kind of i'm just going to say
like it's a kind of child abuse to teach
children over and over and over again
that land theft is the thing that has
been what has happened in human history
and to not talk about the glorious
things and the technological frontiers
and geographic frontiers and the ways
that we have learned to get along with
one another and to merge and to flourish
well it also i think most troublingly
creates no path forward precisely so if
you were to say well
what we should do is we should restore
everything to the people from whom it
was stolen you can't right the point is
you will have to stop arbitrarily the
people who are present are not the
people from whom something was stolen
there's just no mechanism where you
could operationalize anything useful and
i think
it it is important to say first time i
heard a declaration about stolen land i
was actually favorable to it i thought
you know what this is an important
recognition right this is a historical
recognition and a useful one but the
obligation to it the motivation has
become so pathological
and what it doesn't do is focus on the
one answer that addresses all of that
theft right the one answer is to take
what we've got
stabilize it make what we're doing
sustainable and democratize it so
everyone has access and people will make
different amounts of it but the point is
the really abhorrent thing
is that opportunity is so far from equal
right that's the place the focus should
be the way we ended up here is some
story that is going to be arbitrary
depending upon how far back you want to
look and
um so anyway while we are
[ __ ] around with this
stupid
guilt-driven
obnoxious mechanism we are you know
allowing the destruction to continue
and we are avoiding we are running out
the clock while we really have a lot to
do with respect to making the place uh
continually viable for the next 500 or a
thousand years that's right i mean there
were it looks like there were people in
modern new mexico 23 000 years ago how
glorious
how amazing how did they get there what
decisions can we imagine they made that
got them there what technological
innovations did they make while they
were there that allowed them to persist
these are the sorts of questions that i
want
i want to be exploring and i want my
children to be exploring and i want
everyone who's interested in the human
condition and both history and future to
be exploring not just were they
displaced at some point later would
their descendants displaced wrongfully
yeah yeah they were that's one piece of
their story it's one piece yeah and um
you know i
our book talks about the mechanism by
which people figure out how to switch
niches
i would recommend though and we
recommend in the book 1491 which
describes the world in the americas just
before columbus arrived in the new world
right and this
i've called it the greatest story never
told
and the idea is
all of that niche switching produced
this incredible diversity of cultures
and insights and innovations and if
there's one thing we can say about them
we know that they happened completely
independently of the correlated stuff
that happened in the old world because
there was no contact between the old and
the new world right
yeah the mayan enlightenment happened
well before many hundreds of years
before the european enlightenment and it
really is uh you know it's not an exact
match but it's a rough match for
essentially the the greeks and you can
make an argument that the inca were uh
similar in their own way to the romans
that you have this parallelism and these
discoveries which are very human in
their nature the way they come about is
part of this process and most of us
don't know anything about it right so
anyway 1491 is a great way to dive in
and have some sense of what the americas
looked like before europeans came and it
isn't what you've been taught right it's
uh it's an amazing diversity and
highly recommended that's right yeah and
that book 1491 charles c mann i believe
is his name
um wrote a shorter piece and i can't
remember if it was harper's or the
atlantic um that is a great starting
point too if you don't want to if you
don't want to do the whole book it's a
big book
um did you want to talk
briefly about the chinese yes and i
think it actually fits this discussion
yeah and then we'll do a little bit from
roger scrutin before signing off all
right so the story um
which i came to through an ap report
that was circulating uh on twitter i saw
it this morning
uh is about an absolutely impossibly
gigantic chinese fleet of fishing
vessels that are fishing currently off
of south america off of galapagos in
fact they have also done a bunch of
fishing off of
argentina
and chili zach do you want to show that
little video
so this fishing fleet is apparently
currently fishing for humboldt squid
and what you'll see here
is a video these are actual lights this
is taken from space so this giant fleet
of 500 ships uses these giant lights to
attract squid up to the surface which
they're harvesting at an incredible rate
now these animals are very common but of
course many very common creatures have
been hunted to extinction by humans it's
something that we do
and
the the point that needs to be made is
well this is this is resource theft at
some level this is resource stuff but
from whom right right right now there
are in theory
you know maritime laws but these this
fleet appears to be in violation of many
of them these ships turn off the
transponders they're required to have on
nobody knows why but it is something
that is done when somebody is going to
violate maritime rules this you know if
you have the sense of like a fishing
fleet is boats that go out and they do
fishing and they bring back their catch
no no no no no this is a permanently at
sea fleet how are they getting their
catch back well that's the thing is
there are ships that are presumably
transporting things from them and
refueling them at sea and
uh it's incredible there's there's an
indonesian crew there that says they've
been trapped at sea for years on these
boats right so this is not like anything
we have a good model for this is some
impossibly intense
uh
world altering kind of behavior i'm not
arguing that chinese invented this right
there are fleets
harvesting from the world's oceans and
uh and wrecking them but we on land
don't have a good sense for what's
taking place and what its long-term
implications are and we don't have the
structures necessary to say hey actually
that behavior can't go on because you'll
wreck you know you'll you'll wreck this
population and it won't exist for
uh for future humans um there was
something else i wanted to
show but i can't remember
i can't remember what it was
uh so i just oh yeah i know what it was
uh would you show that uh i just wanna
by analogy
point out that the idea that this is
somehow
fishing in the sense that we intuitively
understand fishing and therefore
intuitively have some sense of how
destructive it might be is about like
the idea of loggers
uh
you know cutting down trees right take a
look at what you want to play that zach
um
oh
okay here we go this is what
logging can now look like right this is
a guy one guy
in a
uh like an excavator
operating this object that just
liquidates
trees i mean look at how quickly this
tree is limbed and turned into
identically
sized logs that are ready to go off to
the lumberyard right analog of factory
farming
it's even beyond that it's so it's it's
industrial logging right like you can
imagine an industrial lumber mill but
this is just the liquidation of a forest
surely safer for the people involved no
doubt
and to the extent that there's some
overarching plan about
you know how much
lumber you can harvest
right why not be efficient about it
but on the other hand you can imagine
that if you have the same perverse
incentives you have in every other
industry dictating
uh you know that you'll make your money
liquidating resources in some region can
we take that off yeah that makes me very
sad yeah that video is terrible it's
really terrible and and yet
you know we are consumers we are
consumers of wood yes right um
so you know it
the solution isn't uh no efficient wood
harvesting please right that is not the
solution
but but at some level you're looking at
uh
a world that does not have the
mechanisms necessary to regulate this
kind of power and whether we're talking
about the fishing of humboldt squid or
the harvesting of
lumber we need to be aware that
the rules that we inherited from
18th century visionaries for regulating
how we would interact with each other
just aren't up to the challenge of
dealing with this kind of technology
which means this is why the
the last chapter of the book is the
fourth frontier the idea is we need to
figure out a way that doesn't look like
us liquidating the planet out from under
us
um or we won't survive because that's
what we will continue to do you know the
the ocean issue is
classic tragedy of the commons where you
know if the chinese didn't limit uh
didn't liquidate the humboldt squid out
of the
southern pacific someone else would
right and um obviously it has to be
addressed yes absolutely
um
let me read the final two paragraphs of
this roger scrutin essay it is called
dying in time if i can find it on the
site here
here we go
you can show my screen if you want zach
i'm just going to be reading it
as i scroll
i recommend the entire essay and i'll
link in the in the video description in
the show notes
courage therefore is the cena none of
any attempt to deal with the threat of
senility courage to face the truth and
to live fully in the face of it
with courage a person can go about
living in another way a way that will
give maximum chance of dying with his
faculties intact
this other way is not the way of the
welfare culture in which we are all
immersed it does not involve the
constant search for comforts or the
obsessive pursuit of health
on the contrary it is a way of benign
shabbiness and self-neglect of risky
enjoyments and bold adventures it
involves constant exercise
but not of the body
rather exercise of the person through
relationships with others through
sacrifice through the search for
opportunities to be involved and exposed
such at least is my intuition
the life of benign shabbiness is not a
life of excess of course you should
drink smoke eat fatty foods but not to
the point of gluttony the purpose is to
weaken the body while strengthening the
mind the risks you take should not
damage your will or your relationships
but only your chances of survival
officious doctors and health fascists
will assail you telling you to correct
your diet to take better forms of
exercise to drink more water and less
wine
if you pursue a life of risk-taking in
defiance the thought police will track
you down and your lifestyle will be held
up to ridicule and contempt
it is not that anyone intends you to
live beyond your time
rather to use adam smith's famous image
the old people's gulag arises by an
invisible hand from a false conception
of human life a conception that does not
see death as a part of life and timely
death as the fruit of it
each of us must decide for himself what
the life of benign shabbiness requires
of him
obviously dangerous pursuits like
hunting and mountaineering have a part
to play
equally important is the forthright
expression of opinion so as to with
grateful friends and implacable enemies
a process that enhances both the
constellations of social life and the
tensions of day-to-day living
i am not sure that i could live with my
friend no i am not sure that i could
live like my friend the writer and
campaigner ion hercia lee but there is
an adorable recklessness in her
truth-directed way of life that makes
each moment of it worthwhile
going out to help others in ways that
involve danger in the threat of disease
is also a useful form of exposure the
main point it seems to me is to maintain
a life of active risk and affection
while helping the body along the path of
decay remembering always that the value
of life does not consist in its length
but in its depth
i love this essay i don't agree with all
of it i love reading things which strike
me as um
getting to the heart of an issue in a
way that i had not thought to
and uh coming to conclusions not all of
which i agree with either for
simply
differences in values to some slight
degree but differences in perspective
but
being able to stand in scrutiny shoes
and read this and think
i'm still going to advise our audience
at the end of this show to eat good food
and i don't think of myself as a health
fascist and this is not about
eating well so that you can live to the
absolute uh extension of your possible
life but to eat good food so that you
can do more with the body and the life
that you have
yeah it strikes me this resonates on a
bunch of different levels various things
that we talk about
this is the opposite of reductionism
right i agree with you there's some
things in there that strike me as not i
wouldn't say they're not right but i
would say that they're not universal and
he's making an argument that makes them
sound as if they are
but really the point is look the length
of life
is one factor in an equation of
something that doesn't have a name that
you should be maximizing right
and so the point is yes if you're living
well then living longer gives you more
of that well living which is good
if you are living pointlessly then
lengthening it does very little to
increase the amount of whatever it is
that you might do let's call it meaning
for lack of a better term uh so the
point is you should be monitoring that
thing and you should be balancing how
much do i want to just stick around on
this planet as long as possible against
how much do i want to have you know
pushed the outside of the envelope
before i go you're right how much would
i have liked to have integrated into my
model how much would i have liked to
have contributed to our understanding of
ourselves or something like that and so
you know it isn't very easy
to specify what it is we should be
maximizing but the point is we should be
maximizing something synthetic which
does not which is antithetical to trying
to maximize length of life
that's right
and uh and lots of lots of things are
like this you know um
you know we the even the approach to
punishment for example if you're raising
children or
pets right you you can say well i don't
i don't want to punish well yeah you
shouldn't want to punish but how do you
punish so as to minimize the amount of
punishment it's going to involve
punishing well so that you don't have to
do it very often yeah
if if because you don't like the thing
that needs to be done you do it poorly
you increase the likelihood that you
will have to do more of it in the future
and if you continue to do it poorly you
will create this positive feedback loop
where you create more and more
requirement that you do it and the more
poorly you do it the more requirement
there is for the thing right and we
don't you know this i think this also
goes to
what we talk about with respect to the
importance of interacting with systems
that are not
socially defined
as you are educated or as you educate
yourself because
those systems will
will continue to tell you that if you
try to maximize a single parameter
you'll accomplish nothing right
whereas a
authority figure might tell you oh
that's wonderful you've accomplished so
much and
so if you want to learn these lessons it
might be that you have to step outside
the uh the social in order to even see
them which we do less and less
that's right
all right i think we're there i think we
are i think we're there so uh we thank
you for being here with us this week if
you are watching live uh stick around
we'll take a break as we get the q a set
up and then we'll be back to answer the
questions that you have posed
at uh
darkhorsesubmissions.com
you can also join us tomorrow at my
patreon at 11am pacific for our monthly
uh private q a the questions weren't
even asked but we are able to engage
with people in real time in the chat
there
um we
you may have heard we have this this
book out a hunter-gatherer's guide to
the 21st century and it um will soon
again be available everywhere books are
sold but it is sold out so many places
but we know that at least the beginning
of this podcast it was still available
at barnes and noble so if you're looking
for a copy and you want it soon
um try there hopefully all the supply
chain
blockages will will resolve themselves
soon anything else you want to say no
except uh so many of you have bought it
and thank you um it has it has uh been
very important to us to see how well
received it has been and how eager
people are to read it that's extremely
rewarding and we are grateful yes we're
hoping to start a conversation that goes
across many many borders and
that continues to resonate for many
years to come
so until next time be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
be well everyone
you